welcome to this afternoon session it is
my pleasure to introduce
augusto hirolin
he will talk about uh synchron algorithm
and application to generative models
so thank you very much for the
introduction so thank you
all the organizers for making this
workshop in this very nice program
so
uh i'm gonna talk about the entropic
regularized
optimal transport which is also known in
the literature has the
schrodinger bridge problem
so this is a very
so there is a very vast number of works
in this field so it's a very active
field nowadays
so since we are at the field at the
simons institute i'm gonna take the
point of view of numerix in particular
uh presenting a new variation of
uh
a new variation of strategy new
variation of proof
for the synchron algorithm so the
motivation of my talk will be really
introduce a new proof of the synchron
algorithm that works in the
multi-marginal setting
so before getting into
the core of the talk let me just give
you some context
so like my starting point for for this
presentation
is is like the following problem so it
starts with row one and row two is the
given data two probability measures one
in a space x and another one ui
and i want to minimize the cuba climate
divergence between a transport plant
gamma
and a kernel given by the exponential of
minus c divided by epsilon
among all the transport plants so all
probability measures in the product
space having the marginals equals 2 1 0
2.
so this problem has been exhaustively
studied in different generality
including for more general kernels than
the ones that i'm uh i'm assuming here
but the nice feature about this kernel
when is given by the exponential of
minus c
is that this is equivalent to the
entropic regularization of optimal
transport where the regularization is
given by the channel entropy
so
uh it's very well known under those
generalities that like there exists a
unique solution due to the strictly
convexity of this problem
and this is given by this gibbs energy
exponential of minus c multiplied by two
weights a and b and those weights are
precisely the weights that make gamma
having the correct marginals row 102
so for those uh
familiar with optimal transport so if
i'm matching the red dots so the
distribution row one
with the blue dots the distribution row
two when epsilon it goes to zero i have
straight lines as soon as epsilon
increases
we move to a uh a set where we have
brownian bridges instead of
the displacement interpolation the
amount can displace interpolation
so the effect of the regularization on
the plants is very own also you wanna
make the plant a little bit more fat
so it's not singular with respect to the
product measure row one row two but
become an absolute continuous measure
with uh with respect to row one arrow
two
this is not restricted to the distances
per cost so the set is quite general we
can accommodate for example coulomb
causes that are imported in quantum
chemistry and density functional theory
so in all those different settings we
can show that not only that is the
convergence of the energy so the cost
with epsilon converts as a number to the
ot problem when epsilon goes to zero but
also you have the gamma convergence so
the convergence of the plants for every
sequence of minimizers gamma epsilon
have that this converts to the ot
problem when epsilon goes to zero
so in like how to compute
the
the optimal coupling gum epsilon
so the way of doing this is passing by
solving the schrodinger system
so like the minimizer gum epsilon has
this form if and only
solve with the shielding system the
so-called schrodinger system
which is basically applying the
condition that the gamma belongs to pi
of row 1 2 to this specific shape of the
minimizer
so in general is not possible to solve
this system analytically unless in very
special cases
so last year appear a series of works
were considered the case when you have
the distance square
and row one and row two
are gaussians
so in this case you can solve explicitly
this system
and the reason why is because when you
have gaussians you can take a and b
exponential of quadratic forms so then
you just need to optimize the
coefficients of those forms and you can
solve the system but this is quite
special
in general you need to compute using the
synchron algorithm and i say briefly
what the synchron algorithm is just is
the simplest algorithm
that someone could introduce
so the idea of the synchron algorithm
is that
we initiate we initialize
two vectors a0 and b0
and we defined the sequence a mdn
iteratively
using this structure of the schrodinger
system so i'm just dividing the integral
passing to the other side
and this gives me a iterative way to
define the sequence b n and a n
h at every iteration the idea is that
i'm getting closer to the a and b
that uh
is the solution of the schrodinger
system
so this being has been exhaustively
study like i guess many of the
people who have working this problem is
is or online or in this audience
so there is different proofs for
convergence of
of the synchronous min also approximates
like
the distance linear in time
so just to make a
a
a parallel and try to explain a little
bit of the difficulty
that we we faced so
one approach that was
introduced by cinco and franklin
lawrence and also by train the orgy and
pavon
so i'm very happy to show this in front
of you know right
so the idea is that uh
we can show that like the those
synchronous iterates are like a
contraction under the hubert metric of
the projective cone so the idea
is that you consider cone
of let's say
pi root 2
which are all the sets of transport
plans have one marginal is equal to row
two
and another set
where we have all marginals equal to the
order
and basically you can define a metric on
this cone that roughly speaking
is the angle
and basically you can show that like
every iterations you are fixing
one of the
marginal
and this is a contraction so when the
number of iterates goes to infinity we
are converting today
to the correct one where you have a
epsilon
in the right cost
so the nice feature of this prove that
like you not only give the convergence
but gives to you automatically the rate
of convergence of
of the plan
we get interested in this problem
because we want to understand the
synchron algorithm where instead of
having two marginals you have finitely
many
so instead so then instead of having a
system of two equations you could have a
finite many equations
and uh
we we didn't find a way of uh proving
the convergence of sincorn trying to
adapt these ideas of
the the hubert metric showing that the
synchronous rates are contracted in the
hubert metric because you needed to deal
with fine at many angles
so then we developed a different
strategy
so before going directly to the talk i
just want to mention uh some reference
because this is a very wide topic and
i'm going very focalized in one aspect
of it
so i recommended three surveys so one of
martin indel
from more the numerix and the matrix
viewpoint into beautiful surveys like
with uh more probabilistic large
deviations and is in control aspects
done by leonard jane jordan pavone
very decently
one of those
so the plan of the talk is the following
so i try to introduce
a duality approach
for the entropic regularizer optimal
transport
and the ideas of the those duality
approach is going to give us a
variational proof for the convergence of
the synchron algorithm
although i'm motivated by by the
multi-marginal case you see that like
there is not much difference on doing
this in two or many marginals i'm going
to fix in the two marginal case because
the annotation is much simpler
and if i have some time i'm gonna also
try to present some insights into
generative models
so what is the idea so let's fix
the setting so i have like row one row
two two probability measures
on two polish spaces x and y
the cost function i'm assuming that is
bounded we can also do a similar
analysis when uh the cost is leap sheets
but it's better to keep more general an
epsilon is a positive number so we can
define the dual functional
which is very similar to the classical
contology formulation of optimal
transport with the difference that
instead of the constraint
we have a a penalization given by the
exponential of u plus v minus c divided
by epsilon
in the controversy problem i'm trying to
maximize
the dual problem
assuming that u and v are like in
natural space so the lx expo
like really the the nature of x space
that we should consider such that
the dual function has a finite value
uh
so one important remark is that
the dual functional
for the numerical viewpoint has many
advantages
because this is a unconstrained
uh functional so this is a the
controllability problem in the
regularized case is unconstrained
so
this has been exploited a lot
numerically the advantage of it
but analytically is not so obvious how
to get compactness for this problem
so just to make a parallel so if you
look to the
classicalt problem as soon as we assume
some abundance or some regularity on the
cost c automatically you get also
some regularity for the potentials umd
that you can use to get compactness of
the maximizing sequence now in
particular
we can define the c transform so we can
define like the c transform of u
by the inf
of c x y minus u of x
and automatically if you see sleep
sheets we get automatically that you see
sleep sheets
and you can also have that
we just needed to do this
so
here with this functional because we
don't have this constraint
is not that obvious but there is a
equivalent object that does the job and
the object is like is the entropic
transform
or the c epsilon transform
that is defined like the log sum x
of those potentials
and this is really the right object that
allow us to get some regularity on the
potentials to
to get compactness of the maximizing
sequence so in particular properties of
the cost function so for example if
these leap sheets or omega continuous
translate into the properties of the
potentials
uh another property that is important
for the convergence is that if c is
bounded
dc epsilon transform or this entropic
transform
is our lips it's compact operator
between l infinity and lp
and of course you have also like a
geometric property system concave with
respect to a variable
also the potential is going to be
so and this is very consistent to the to
the classical case when you have epsilon
equals to zero because like by the
laplace principle when you send epsilon
to zero you recover here the c
transformer
so you can really see this as a
regularization of the sequence form
so and with this in hand with this in
mind so we can show that like the
supremum
of the dual problem
is
reached by unique couple u 0 v 0 of
course
we have some symmetry of the dual you
can add the subtract a constant
and this does not change the value of
the cost so like you can show that there
is this one up to trivial
transformations
and in particular both are l infinity
because we assume that the cost is
bounded
this symmetry is something that uh a
plays a role to make the problem a
little bit more difficulty
but like we can use the c transforms
to deal with this symmetry so like we
can show that there exists
two potentials you start this star
that are bounded
and in particular there exists a
constant
that one potential is the c transform of
the other so you can get indeed with
this symmetry playing a little bit more
with this epsilon transform
with all of these like
to show the existence of the maximizer
is basically apply the direct method of
the calculus of variations
so we pick two maximizing sequence apply
the c epsilon transforms to get the
boundness of the potentials
via dilemma
then by banaca log loop we get
convergent subsequence
and then the existence of the maximizer
follows by the upper semicontinuity of
the dual functional
so it's really like a very classical
calculus operations approach to the to
the existence of the maximizer
okay so that is the idea
um
to summarize what we can get is like
all the following are equivalent so
there exists the two maximizers of the
dual problem
one is the c epsilon transform of the
other
if you plug u and v if you take
exponential of u an exponential of v
the following gamma solved the
schrodinger system so they have the
correct marginals and in particular it
solves the schrodinger system because
the unique one who have this form
and you have like uh the primal dual
condition so like the primal problem
coincides with the dual problem
and one remark
is that
in some applications could be natural
instead of using the regularization like
has a reference measure row 1 tensor row
two
it could be natural for example to use a
reference measure in a manifold
so you could uh instead of using the
regular regularization
of the entropy with respect to row one
row two with a general reference measure
this does not play any game in our
analysis
because one problem is basically uh
up to a constant they have the same
value
and to do the existence of the
potentials you just need to work with
the correct potentials by shifting by
minus epsilon log the density so all the
analysis that we are doing here works
regardless of the reference measure that
we choose
so it's going to change a little bit to
the definition of the c transformer but
like the the proof goes in the same way
so the the reference measure does not
play important role
and also
everything since everything is
variational all the previous analysis
can be extended to the multi marginal
case so if you have two or finitely many
works it's going to work in the same way
so why we are interested just one slide
to to try to say that this is useful so
like in the multi-margin optional
transport like has been appearing in
different contexts so
has like the time discretization of
euler equations
has vassa's time body centers
also in quantum chemistry in density
functional theory like optimal transport
with coulomb costs become very important
very recently
also connections between multi-margin
optimal transport and probabilistic
graphical models any mathematical
economics like matching for teams so the
structure of the problem is the same
instead of have two you have finitely
many but the notations become a little
bit heavy
so previous to us there was a very nice
article by carliele board
that showed existence uniqueness and
smooth dependence with respect to of the
multi-margin of schrodinger's system
assuming that the data are in l infinity
so which is a little bit orthogonal of
what we did
so now let me go to the
to the proof of convergence
of uh
the synchron algorithm
so i
mentioned again like how is the
philonega system so we initialize two
sequence a0 and b0 and they define
bnaan in the following way
in the theorem which is in the two
marginal cases is very well known to two
works like if you pick the epfp or
synchron sequence
then there exists a constant a sequence
of constants like lambda n
such that a n converges in any p to a
b n converges in
lp to b
for any p
where a and b solve the chelonegal
system and in particular we not only get
the convergence of the potentials but we
also get the convergence of the plants
so in what is the idea
the idea to prove this is very similar
to the
analysis of the duo
the only remark that we need to make
is that
if we do a change of variable
in instead of looking in terms of a n
and b n we want to look in terms of
potentials u n and v n
so if you do this change of variable
in the schrodinger system
let's say for the first one then by
applying the log
in both sides
we get basically that vn
is minus exponential
the log
of the integral in x
of e
of
n minus one
of x minus c of x and y
integrated in row one of x
so i'm integrating one l of x so this
gives me a function of y
and this is precisely
the
a u n minus 1
c epsilon transform
so basically what we are doing when you
are
computing the the sync on iterates
you are basically doing a c epsilon
transform
so and as you know dc epsilon
transformer
gives me a increasing sequence in the
dual problem
so the idea goes very similar to the
proof of existence of
of potentials because like
by applying the c transformer
you get some regularity
on the synchron sequences
so we can show that there exists a a
constant such that
u n minus elena the enema plus ln are
bounded
that sequence u n v n increases and is
bounded by the primal problem
and thanks to the property that this
epsilon transformer is our lipsticks
compact operator
you get also that those sequence are
pre-compacting lp
so the only work to do now is to compute
the limit
between the epsilon transform and v
the same for rule to get the convergence
because if you know that one is the
epsilon transform of the order they are
the maximizers of the dual potential the
dual the dual problem
so getting the convergence of the
when the nlp is easy to translate this
to the convergence of the plans so it's
really it's a completely variational
problem variational proof of the
synchron algorithm
and again
the previous strategy is not limited for
n equals 2 but
you can use the finitely many
there was a work of carlson ring in 2017
that used a similar strategy in the
discrete case to prove the convergence
of the multi-marginal synchron algorithm
so all our work you can see has an
extension of this work when you have
continuous
probability measures
and very recently like a couple of
months ago
carlier
used using this methodology also get the
rate of convergence so like the
disadvantage of this method things is
poorly variational we get the
convergence but we don't know the rate
which is different when you use the
contraction on the huberty metric that
is for free
but like doing some work we can also get
the linear rate of convergence of this
problem
so just a remark
i guess it's going as expected so
this can be generalized for more general
entropies so like
imagine now that you wanna do
a regularized optimal transport problem
but instead of choosing the channel
entropy you wanna choose a general
entropy so and by a general entropy
i consider a convex lower
semi-continuous function that is super
linear at infinity
i assume that like it behaves well like
it's zero in one in the derivative of
one but this is just for simplicity this
is not a restrictive condition
anyone defined a similar problem so the
motivation of using different
regularizations
comes from the sparsity of the plane for
example you can see in the quadratic
case that even epsilon is very big you
still get a solution that is very sparse
uh this has been studied previously of
course for the channel entropy for the
sales entropy in the context of
ecological inference
and in the quadratic case by many
authors
and uh the general case has been looked
at
very recently so in the discrete case in
2018
and then in 2019 2020 in the continuous
case but the settings were a little bit
different so the difference between our
work and the work of lawrence and mahler
is that in our work you can see that we
really consider gamma
as uh absolutely continuous
with respect to the product measure
while
in
their work the the work of florence
gamma is absolutely continues with a
reference measure and unfortunately in
the convex in the general case where you
have a convex entropies those are not
equivalent
and in our case
it's easier because since we are
regularizing with respect to the
product measure
we can get a similar regularity of the
potentials what is which is not true in
the in their case
so very very recently so all the other
authors consider the a similar problem
so
uh this year
uh terre haken gonzalez sanchez relax
the hypothesis of superlinearing at
infinity so considering like more
general f divergence regularizations and
last week like uh
x and marcelonates
did some
quantitative stability of this problem
as well
and can also deal with the with the
distance square case in two marginal so
with the
the the distance
so in what we can get here is very
similar
so the primary dual problem coincides
and moreover
you have an optimizer a unique optimizer
for the problem
gum epsilon
which has a very similar shape
so phi star is the
convex conjugate of psi
of phi sorry phi star is the conjugate
of phi
so the plan has like the derivative of
the convex conjugate
and here you have the two control
potentials minus c divided by epsilon
so the strategy is very similar but we
can look uh
a little bit more abstract what are the
the
entropy transform when you have a
general entropy
so the idea is that
we define
so here should be a belongs right so
here we define the entropy transform by
taking the arg max of the dual potential
with respect to one variable
which you can show that is equivalent to
solve this problem
which is very nice that gives a very
nice implicit equation
that is precisely the generalization of
the schrodinger system when you have a
gen a general entropy
so if you have the similar equation with
row 2 where we maximizing v we would
have the precisely the the children
system with
a general entropy
and thanks to this we can get
a
similar a similar structure so assuming
some regularity don't see
this also translates to the
to the
to the epsilon epsilon transform of the
potentials
so in particular if c is bounded if c
sleep sheets we get the same for the
potentials and it's also a one liter
compact operator
so and then having all of these in hands
we can now look at the synchron
algorithm in a different way
and define the phi synchron algorithm
for a general entropy
by basically the alternating
maximization of the dual problem where i
just maximize with respect to u keep the
d fixed
and the second iteration i maximize with
v keeping you fixed
and this gives me like the
similar updates so i initialize
uh u0 v0 and compute the next u
by solving please delete this equation
and compute v by solving completely this
equation
so in the proof of uh convergence goes
in the same way
we need like the compactness of the
entropy transform
plus the fact that like all the time
that i apply the entropy transform i'm
increasing on the dual functional so i'm
getting
a higher value of the dual functional
that is bounded by
the primal primal problem
so just
a last remark
we can also get in in
also in the convex regularizer the
thresher differential of the lt problem
so here there is a typo
here should be phi star so the convex
conjugate of of phi
so what you get that like both the
sequence are weakly converging so the ot
problem is continuous
the convex regularization problem is
continuous and also like the gradient is
well defined
where like the gradient you can compute
in terms of the optimal potentials u and
v
so just to
mention briefly
how this can be used to
understand the some problems on
generative models i know that uh doom is
going to talk more about this later so
i'm just going to mention briefly
so vases time becomes very popular in in
the context of
generative adversarial networks
because of the
power of generate
realistic images
so those images that are
uh generated here are of uh people that
does not exist
but that uh was learning from a data set
of celebrities so this was done by
people from nvidia
so in alto and helsinki university
so and there was a very important
threshold of the use of a vast destiny
distance in this context
so like very briefly speaking because i
know that there are other at least the
two talks about the the subject on these
on this workshop so the idea of guns
that you have uh
a generator and discriminator
so the generator starts with poorly run
rundown noise
and try to challenge the discriminator
to distinguish what is a real or a fake
image
comparing to the training set
and the discriminator acts as a guy who
needs to to
to be able to distinguish between what
is a real image that came from the data
set or what is a fake image that the the
generator is
is producing
so the main idea of the vasestan gun so
the paper of 2017 was to replace the
original setup of young good fellow that
used this channel
jensen channel divergence for the
discriminator to replace this
discrimination for the dual formulation
of the one vascular distance this one
so in a after that there was a paper
that is called wngp so the gradient
penalty that improved a little bit to
the training so and very roughly
speaking so the idea
is like to solve
uh
the duo the the dual of the one vices
and distance using neural networks
so basically we exploit a very nice
property of the one versus the distance
that the c transform
of one potential is basically minus the
potential itself so and then the the
dual conditions here so the constraint
you can really write has like one of x
minus one of y
is smaller than the one the distance
cost
and this is basically saying that like
your potential is like one lip sheets so
it's lipschitz with a constant one
so the biggest problem is really like to
enforce this lipshis constraint when we
parameterize use using neural networks
so in the paper wgn gp so gradient
penalty
they reinforce this literature's
constraint by penalizing the gradient of
the
of the controlling potential
doing this soft regularization
here and uh
this was very impressive because you
really were able to to this worked very
well
when you are doing tasks like density
estimation generation
but what was very surprising to me is
that when you do this
gradient penalty
you are actually not learning the
control over potentials so in the sense
that so we did a comparison
which like the the true w1 distance
computing on the midi batteries
is given by those uh
those black dots
that is here
so and when you compute this using a c
transform approach what you would do in
general when you compute exactly so you
really see that like the c transform
approach coincides with the
with the true vascular distance
so the c transform approach using neural
networks
while if you use this gradient penalty
you have like a huge difference
between what is the true value of the
vast and distance
and the
in the potential that is learned by
the degrading penalty method so the same
happens when you use the c epsilon
transform
and then entropic regularization so when
we understood that like devices the the
vast standing approach are not really
learning the the optimal discriminate
the optimal potential in the sense of
you know like the one that solves the
optimal transport problem but getting a
suboptimal solution that works very well
so
we also made some uh experiments to see
the stability so like the c epsilon
transform where i use epsilon equals to
one is very stable when we compute our
mini batteries so like the red is like
the one that we compute using neural
networks and the blue is the one that we
compute exactly the western distance so
we take a very small number of mini
batches so we can compute this
uh with it reasonably fast using the
using exact solver
while if you see the gradient penalty
there is an enormous discrepancy and
it's very stable
when you compare with the true one
and what is very
surprising for us is that despite the
fact
you are not learning the optimal
potential so you are not learning the
the real controversy potential
when you are talking about
generation tasks
the gradient penalty and the weight
clipping do much better than the c
epsilon transformer although we learned
the better potentials
so the the c epsilon transform and the c
transformers you you convert to a sort
of k means of images
while with few iterations with the
gradient penalty you converge to things
that looks like a face
and this was very surprising to us so we
look a little bit uh in the literature
together with a
excellent mastery student like lauren
kotov that is in the university of
amsterdam
so he
went to a little bit on the literature
and did some experiments by himself
so he managed to deal with the small
data sets
using the entropic regularization and
like a c epsilon
approach or mini batches so if you have
like low dimensional sets like uh
gaussians like mixed gaussians he's able
to learn very well with like a different
values of epsilon not too big
not too big means epsilon 40.
also with deminings work very well of
course when epsilon increases you get
some bias
but again when you get a database that
is too big
big means between eminence and celebrity
a this does not work very well
this epsilon approach learn better the
potentials so are closer to what be the
the true entropy control which potential
but are very far away
of being a good enough to generate
images
uh
and there are very nice theoretical and
experimental insights
so one was by
julica martino that she conjecture
that uh
the weakness of the divergence or the
weakness of the distance so it's not
really a good indicator for sample
generation
so we like a lot of the idea that using
the vases time
uh may improve uh
the gun training
but this may be not true so
the weak the weakness of the divergence
don't play an important role
and actually what i learned from lorien
that is like a hyperparameter
highlighter affects the performance of
the jensen
shenangan so if you are very good on
dealing with neural networks to find a
very good architectures
you can get very realistic images even
using the
jensen channel divergence
and what seems to play a very important
role in this context this was a finding
by jan that is a ph edition of carola
that it seems that like enforcing the
one leap its constraint seems to play a
role that's much more important than
really finding a nice way of learning
the optimal potential to find really the
maximizer of the optimal potential so
there are experiments where you
regularize it with the lip sheets
regularization
the jensen channel entropy that works as
good as the wngp or very close to the
ngp
even if there is no theory that justify
to use this
this regularization
and also like there is also the curse of
dimensionality of devastating
devastating distance so that seems that
like you you learn when you are doing
mini batch
a false global optima in the sense that
like the kind of minimum that you you
learn when you are doing
a sample estimate of the western
distance is different from the global
minimum
and i like a lot of this paper
that they summarize those ideas in a
very nice way in a very beautiful way
that retains in the mind that is like
vases then going works because they fail
to approximate the devices and distance
and i guess this is a very nice message
that's saying that
you don't need to learn the optimal
potentials
to be able to do very good generation
tasks
so when i don't know i may stop here so
thank you very much
thank you thank you any question
thank you so much um so the c epsilon
transform involves a an integral which
is high dimensional i guess if you have
high dimensional data how do you do that
numerically monte carlo so you just
approximate with monte carlo
it's true that is high dimensional but
since you are doing
you are solving this using back
propagation so you just need batches of
size i don't know 64 or 228 so this is
doable with monte carlo
and in theory the error is very small
i think all the mini batches of course
if you go to celebrity maybe huge
but very nice question
okay
[Music]
okay very nice
now this can be very very because we
don't have the additive property of the
exponential which is very handy to to
write explicitly their iterations
so one way very stupid to do this is
really to do gradient ascent in one of
the variables
so one way of doing this is really like
thinking simcorn has an alternate
maximization of the dual problem the
dual problem with uh convex legalization
is unconstrained
so you can really do this like using i
don't know stochastic gradient
percentage one of the variables for
example
or you can really solve with this guy
using some newton's method like those
are the two ways that i would approach
numerically this problem
the nice thing that we know that those
two
ways are equivalent so you're going to
go to the same to the same solution
but i agree like i don't know i i i
i'm not very good in programming so i
think like uh we needed to think a very
clever way of
often using this
more efficiently
for a while is a very nice algorithm
that works on the on the blackboard
but for a general fi
it can be very it's much more expensive
than than uh
than the classical sim card
so if you have the quadratic is not that
bad
it's very fast as well
now that i'm saying about this
uh
during the boot camp
uh marco kuturi presents a way of
solving simcorn using like automatic
differentiation
or implicit differentiation
and uh one question that asks to him is
it's like he present everything using
the channel entropy
but actually the the way that they he he
compute the the solution
does not matter the regularization that
you have
so you could also use like implicit
differentiation and
it's going to work in the same way so i
would say if you want to compute this
efficiently more in that direction than
using classical ideas of simcore
yes
by saying that one guy does better than
the other no i mean so it's really like
the imetry in so there are two ways that
i can say no one guns do better than the
other if in the i metric
i generate better images than the others
and here i don't know like i would be
very happy that my gun would work but i
i cannot say that so is much worse on
the generation task here you get
realistic images here not
another way of saying that is better or
not better is like which one
are computing more accurately
control over potentials because like you
could completely forgot guns
and say
i want to find a way of computing using
neural networks device is symmetric a
way of estimating the vast system metric
using neural networks
so in that sense i would say that the c
epsilon transform do better
than uh than the gradient penalty or the
weight clipping because they their
estimates on mini batches
are close to the
in the epsilon transform case and not in
the gradient penalty
[Music]
so i say that like on the if you if you
are interested in generation generate
nice images we do worst
if you are interested in estimated
versus the metric we do better
obviously one thing that the gun is
supposed to do this is supposed to
produce pretty looking images another
thing is supposed to actually give you
something that looks like a sample from
the distribution of interest right so
and something that again could do is it
could just memorize you know one real
image of the face and just give you a
thousand copies of them and that would
pass the eye test the flying colors
right but there's
some additional um like
uh there should be some technical way to
check whether
the batch actually looks like a
reasonable bash sample right so is that
is that the second
no it's not something that we look at
really we did a very naive approach of
looking really look for the image then
pick one that you find that is
which one you would buy
but like the question that we are more
interested is it was like how well we
can estimate in the last condition
because like it's it's a problem itself
like how to compute it in higher
in higher dimensional data sets
and uh and i would say that like the cxl
and transport approach works better in
that sense
and then just briefly the very very last
comment and very last slide i think and
this is uh very interesting so there
there's um there's some work they
shouldn't turn yeah with his
collaborators on uh uh looking at the
regularity of laundry pair equation and
how that
fits into some of the stuff in the gun
literature so in particular uh if you
think that the distribution of bait mode
of like
the support of the face manifold or
whatever is going to be some non-convex
thing in the spaceball images but the
regular launch of error tells you that
if you actually learned the ot map then
you would the the um
support of the
the push forward measure has to be
convex
so
this is sort of another point in favor
of this last comment that if you
actually learned the ot map successfully
then
you would only get one mode
you should send me these
i don't know but just one thing that is
important i want to make publicity
because i really like this article
that says really the double gun
don't work because they fail i think
that is but i know that he's going to
speak this week so that's why i
mentioned very briefly
so the question was just on the gradient
penalty
so in the gradient penalty
so
why
so why is that enforcing right
like
gradient u equals one everywhere and not
gradient two less or equal than one
everywhere
that is a good point
so
did someone tried also the inequality
because maybe it plays a role right
right so it's
i don't know so from the point of view
of
the results
good point no we didn't
[Music]
at least i don't know like zero
yeah but when you do all mini batches
right the square
the square should be outside
is a very rough approximation
that is a miracle that works very well
so i think we should stop here to get
ready for the nestor thank you again
thank you very much
[Applause]